au départ la des shows on a un petit
goût comité on allait manquer ça
rappelle un peu la star ac
[Musique]
un nouveau comité d'accueil j'ai pas pu
partir en tunisie mais regardez j'ai
quand même une super belle vue sur la
piscine molitor
je voulais les remercier toute l'équipe
parce qu'ils sont trop formidable merci
beaucoup pour l'accueil concernant les
numéros de téléphone d'un fêlé mac notre
amie julie de vendays l'ag l'eau
l'inquiète je me dis juste ce qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui alors je peux pas vous dire je peux
rien vous dire je veux dire que c'est
magnifique
regardez la piscine autre belle et
derrière la mer et gros gros programme
sa prison dit tout et plein plein de
gros mots vifs
[Musique]
du fait des deux
tu donnes tu lui donnes ta genou et ne
jamais
[Musique]
je ne savais pas
pour le numéro de téléphone donc
j'appelle ce numéro de téléphone depuis
mes 12 ans donc merci merci à tous en
tout cas non merci pour les messages
c'est super gentil mais bon voilà quoi
qu'il en soit maintenant la ligne c'est
plus la mienne donc voilà et de toute
façon vingt deux jours je pars à fort
boyard donc j'aurai j'aurais dû écourter
mon voyage en tunisie de toute manière
donc c'est pas grave et je fais des gros
bisous à tous avec mon ami mokhtar de
l'opow tout se passe bien mon ami on a
besoin de ces fonds lorsqu'ils c'est
vraiment super en forme c'est tout le
banc du coup de tonnerre
chance d'ailleurs j'espère beau ça c'est
très beau ça et à toutes et à tous
gatouillat touya tout il est là lui
c'est le responsable de tout ça et là
y'a de leurs mollets toniques ans
affirme c'est plus les gens et que ce
qui compte c'est la solidarité l'amour
suit à quelques 4 4
voilà bravo c'est bien celle là est ce
décor la loi c'est génial change rien
mathieu et voilà un mec qui filme un
autre mec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]